[Music]
and let the games begin new submitted by
Hendrick that's what a whole say when
they go out on a Friday night let the
games begin
yeah those gonna be Hendrick I'm like
huh she yeah yeah they also take a
Charlie Charlie's Angels picture too
yeah she's going with this let the games
begin
wait what's with the changes Ella we
posed hoes before on a safari on fire
tonight
oh they posed a Charlie Daniels post
thing I swear to god I see it that's
what I say whoa go rapper he was waiting
for me to join that so I saw him on the
screen just keep saying what's the games
begin unconventional sports are now
being legitimized across the world what
is the unconventional yeah we can we can
we can swapping yeah there you go
lightsaber fighting I heard that's a
terrible one before we get carried away
oh my favorite dueling has been
officially recognized by the French
Fencing Federation not that they're
gonna be wow but this is that kind of it
is like fencing you're just it's doing
it with a laser I guess a fake laser cuz
it's really just a piece of plastic I
think you're really serious
anti-bullying Chow can I just say
anti-bullying activists are you happy
now are you happy now because this would
have been stopped at a local level much
earlier I want this big let me show you
guys the video do you not like to laugh
it watch this [ __ ]
[Music]
basic rule number one
watch hot young padawan oh he's gonna
bring it back to strike okay hey Liam
you know we should do it on a party in
LA that kurtz miss your movements
[Music]
prettier wow these things don't break
when they smash them against each other
oh we're not gonna watch oh I've seen
them in real life
Google a duel I know people that are
part of these Sabre group world peoples
they have different like levels to
remember star wars kid that's all I
think about
mm-hmm Star Wars kid the kid that was
swimming at my I'm setting me to young
so he was this kid in his room and he
made this video of him going like Shh
and he was making all the sounds and
stuff and like he was doing this Bank
and then someone found it and you're
edited it to make it like actual lives
yeah yeah no but he got made fun of it
was actually his digital media class
where he filmed it you use their cameras
and [ __ ] I like that you know the
history yes it's a very famous tree then
they just released the video of him like
[ __ ] up and like hitting the wall the
best part of that is there was like a
blanket in the back yeah he was so into
it that his foot slipped on it sure did
yeah many times and they had the slo-mo
and [ __ ] zoom in on that part of it
and a mr. best part is that is the
intense look that he has at the end of
each one where he's like I just [ __ ]
up these guys man
it's like those kids that um that cut
the sodas with the knives and they're
just like the heat knives and they like
they get really like into it like
they're [ __ ] murdering all they're
bullies right now like I think it's so
seriously that the ancient art that was
invented three weeks ago that goes like
they channeled that inner solid
: [ __ ] water Jack I know some of them
have like five set up and they're like
it's usually so there's one behind them
at the end for the puppies oh yeah for
now oh god I love these guys it's
usually a really fat dude with this
bottom belly yeah yeah yeah it's the
best that's how the lightsaber fighting
guys look man I love this [ __ ] yeah yeah
so they're saying like the federation is
saying that they've just hope to have
more kids come out and try this out so
they're not stuck at home like staring
at a screen or whatever so that's what
could I'll agree with that they should
replace shot put with this in the
Olympics yeah great speaking of the
Olympics though there are four
additional sports expected to be
included in the 2024 Olympic karate
Harris yeah two of them are karate gonna
be all the ones I have is breakdancing
surfing's sport climbing and
skateboarding whoa extreme sports that's
it damn all the skate vets and surf vets
BAM they made this should happen yeah
remember the X Games yeah hmm just
little things I don't know what you can
hot dog guys get in the hot dog guy or
poker is on ESPN also I know I like
poker ah it's fun yeah so they were
targeted with pretty good did 2020 games
in Tokyo it is karate baseball softball
there as well as squash squash that's
ridiculous my whole not bad man man dude
and Cummins business that's silly
Penta K is also little thing goes it's
absurd you know the one that could get
rid of and this is winter in the pics
but that [ __ ] sorry if you like it
but not really sorry that [ __ ] disc
where they're just like slow shuffle
are they chipping away at the ice to
make your move they do I don't know
terrible I [ __ ] hate that they are
shooting or [ __ ] with the cold is it a
ghost shuffle something let's [ __ ]
get rid of it extremely synchronize
going up it looks so funny cuz I'm just
like it looks like you they're kind of
vacuuming or something yeah when people
become like an Olympic pro at one of
those sports that don't matter it's kind
of like you're not really in the
Olympics
that's like Steve's trophy that we were
just talking about this country
daddy you bringing it back she was have
a bad day Niki's I have a bad feeling
she'll never take away my achievement my
achievements with me forever holding Oh
Carly yes and then another one that was
with that's gonna be in 2020 so it's
squash you're like what is that and then
this other one Pat Hungate what is that
that's a lawn game similar to Bulls
played chiefly in Provence I nominate or
airsoft but 10k the sport that falls
into the category of bull sports along
with Rafa Bosch bullion neighs blonde
what are you saying
green bowling what about laser tag yes
I nominate airsoft laser tag second dude
later tag paintball paintball I was
gonna say that I also nominate ass
grabbing yeah I want to talk for that
one
no it's couples it's couple tag what are
the actual rules attached Kylie no
playground rules you have to tell
someone
yeah but it depends freeze tag are you
playing whoa
hide-and-seek plus tag no the one that I
saw were these two guys in this arena
type of thing and there's all these
obstacles it kind of looks like parkour
type of obstacles and it's just one
against one and I've seen that too no
one gets yeah it's over it's so that's
so silly but so are a lot of sports if
you think about it dude just watching
dodgeball is infinitely more
entertaining than a lot of different
Olympics work yeah that's true some of
the Olympic sports are like man you have
too much athletic ability for that
shitty ass game hmm that game is so
shitty like chess is cool why don't have
chess and [ __ ] the Olympics is boring
to watch unless you're playing I think
it needs to be some sort of physical
exertion not aesthetic yeah Dever I
guess mafia should be Olympic sport
that'd be so sick how about jacking off
you just think nor do you got these you
look at this direction just to complete
a thought no I'm saying that I disagree
and I think that mental games are just
as important as physical games and well
we're not seeing the importance part
we're just in the Olympics part of the
grounds of what the Olympics were
grounded on it's supposed to be yes so
it could be a mental because going back
as golf in it give a house curling in
the third who's like I don't know no
semantics for it all it is damn Golf is
Olympic sport how about bowling
Jesus I dunno it's bowling Olympic sport
I feel like yeah we're about what about
table hockey Oh that'd be good looks
crazy golf was added in 2016 and bowling
it's not oh I guess the other way around
how about bowling I'll never get his
chances on dude how about how about
deep-sea fishing this is bowling at the
Summer Olympics when wikipedia bowling
was featured in the some Summer Olympic
Games demonstration program in 1988 at
the souls royal bowling center that was
the peak of bully 80s and 90s and then
they got bored yeah yeah people people
realize that there are other sports in
2015 it was announced that bowling made
the cut from the 28 sports to the last
eight to become the new sport in 2020
Summer Olympics oh my god really
so it's finally happening hasn't
happened yet but it's happening how
about my throwing I need to come back
here though how about knife throwers
oh my god Jeff what about darkness
darkness I think darts is a I think
darts is ugh be [ __ ] early
I played the cross for a little bit the
cross is not a you [ __ ] liar we fell
I believe in lacrosse his wife what's
the cross you're holding the thing up
here and then you throw it and you're
trying to catch it with Oh with us the
[ __ ] nut sack ball well you can not
people like hot like it's straight
strike yeah that's the cool part of the
cross I don't know cuz I never remember
the age that I was and you can check
people with their shoulder they're
running full speed
I didn't play for very long at all I
played thank you like play do you mean
you tried out and then need a Mickey
either like here we're gonna try this
game out
no no cuz I played a lot of sports live
ever leave me to if you know that I
played flag football I play tennis
freeze tag tennis badminton
I'm not almost on a lot of leagues every
week I was on I want to play yeah
oh my mom you see that Outrigger in
Hawaii yeah anyway I would watch them
and go that looks so fun out rigging
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]